bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous alors
entre temps on a eu des informations a
priori de source gouvernementale citée
par l' agence france-presse
pas de confinement globale ça on le
savait plus ou moins n'est pas de
confinement non plus le week-end comme
beaucoup le craignent et en ile de
france et à paris c'est en tant que chef
des urgences d'un hôpital parisien une
décision qu'on vous déplorez de
nouvelles si on se dit que l'intérêt de
la population et on vérifie si un peu
plus de liberté d'un peu plus verte et
vous voir sortir ni les week-ends je
vais rester
de facto nous sommes problème et est de
facto nous sortir aujourd'hui c'est très
difficile de faire des pronostics parce
que tout et couvre donc il y avait été
fait e sont modifiées par le faire il y
à des interventions d'un portage du
mastrou d'utilisation des parce que le
confinement la nuit chacun d'entre nous
sont restreints dans certaines règles
sociales ont rencontré les personnes
âgées ou en off
nous habitons d'entrée certains de vos
proches votre vie sociale réduite donc
toutes les tous les modèles
mathématiques on avait alors ne marche
plus donc c'est très difficile de se
prononcer il est vrai la situation est
très tendue dans les hôpitaux nous son
temps qu'il y a et semaine avec une
petite diminution et des semaines avec
une petite augmentation et notre grosse
crainte c'est qu'à un moment les choses
aux puissances s'emballer et que notre
capacité de réserve n'existe pas nous
n'allons pas une capacité de réserve
suffisante aux gens et dans les hôpitaux
dans les départements qui sont très
touchées actuellement pour pouvoir
répondre à l afflux massif de patients
effectivement plus de 3600 personnes
atteintes de coville était soigné en
réanimation
ce soir soit le chiffre le plus haut
depuis fin novembre c'est quelque chose
qui nous arrivait
a expliqué la faute aux variants oui il
ya le marion qui expliquent une partie
le à riom un avantage génétique et il
s'est imposé aujourd'hui en région
parisienne plus de 70 80 % des patients
infectés sont en fait des parades des
variantes donc il s'est imposé ils
expliquent une partie de l'augmentation
du nombre de cas le danger c'est que une
fois qu'il a pris la place de tous les
virus lui il continua symbole et à son
volet et je comprends que nos
compatriotes dont concitoyens sont
épuisés en même temps la france est un
grand pays et chacun d'entre nous doit
faire preuve de son engagement dans
l'intérêt collectif dans l'intérêt de
toute la population
on protéger chacun chacun de leurs êtres
chers c'est cet indispensable cet
engagement de chacun on protéger toute
la population le lac au vide c'est pas
une maladie banale
il ya même pour les personnes qui n'ont
pas fait d'effort le graal il ya des
conséquences à moyen et long terme pour
les personnes qui peut faire des formes
graves
c'est une épreuve difficile
l'étouffement la difficulté respiratoire
être en réanimation est loin d'être
anodin que ce que j'anime à doha la base
j'ai travaillé pendant des années en
réanimation
c'est une épreuve chacun des patients
donc ce n'est pas quelque chose d'anodin
notre rôle est de protéger tous nos
concitoyens et pour cela malgré les
progrès dans la vaccination nous devons
continuer à respecter réel de
distanciation les règles aux barrières
c'est d'un engagement civique essentiel
de chacun d'entre nous on a justement
c'est bien que leur allié américain
casalino parce qu'on en a un petit peu
le sentiment de pas de france mais voilà
un camp qui on peut pas parler de qu'en
mai
une partie de la population qui semble
très loin de ce virus peut-être voilà
qui fait quand des personnes plus jeunes
ne le voit pas ce virus le gouvernement
qui tente quand même de nous encourager
qui dit que les premiers effets de la
vaccination se font sentir qu'ils voient
une sortie de crise peut-être à la mi
avril et cette situation vous le
décrivez dans les services d'urgences
avec des chiffres qui sont inquiétants
vous comment vous vous situez vous êtes
plutôt aussi dans le camp quand même des
optimistes la fin du tunnel c'est pour
bientôt
on vous suit bien sûr ministre et je
suis plein de courageux et plein
d'enthousiasmé je suis certaine que
l'immense majorité des français c'est
pareil ça n'empêche que nous devons être
réalistes aujourd'hui nous devons
continuer à respecter les règles de
distanciation
nous devons nous engager de tous pour
maxime et tous nos concitoyens qui ont
des critères de fragilité qui nécessite
une bonne pâque six nations sont les
premiers qui vont aux baissiers
nous devons continuer à protéger les
personnes les plus fragiles en faisant
très attention
allez vite faire attention de garder la
distance de porter le masque
il faut surtout pas penser que le combat
est gagné d'avancé
aucun combat n'est gagné d'avancé et
nous devons continuer même si l'horizon
paraît un peu plus serein avec l'idée de
l'arrivée les bons jours dès le mois
d'avril
nous devons rester raisonnable très
prudent et les pays où l'épidémie est
très important malgré le fait qu'il fait
chaud on verra mais le brésil c'est un
très bon exemple
ce qui est arrivé dans le département
d'amazones d'amazonas au brésil
il fait chaud et pourtant les billets
mis à flamber
donc nous devons être extrêmement
prudent continuer à respecter les règles
et être très engagé pour nous protéger
nous mêmes et protéger l'ensemble des
concitoyens
dernière question n'ont pas à être les
évidemment c
c'est une équipe principale mais pas que
les vaccins astrazeneca
ça n'a pas donné les résultats qu'on
attendait puisqu'il ya beaucoup de
réticences même y compris chez des
soignants johnson and johnson on attend
la semaine prochaine
unizo cela peut changer la donne pour
vous il y a une mauvaise information sur
le versant d'astrazeneca
il ya eu des informations d'abord sur
des effets indésirables
s'il ya les effets indésirables mais
rien d'extraordinaire
il a eu une mauvaise information et
désinformation concernant son éventuelle
non efficacité sur le maillot
sud-africain
ça a été aussi finalement un peu
contesté aujourd'hui tous les vaccins se
valent aujourd'hui la priorité c'est de
se vacciner
je pense que notre conseil doit être de
bien aux français va signer vous avec le
médecin qu'on vous propose qui est
disponible c'est celui là qui est le bon
il est là et vous allez en bénéficier
tous ces vaccins sont très efficaces ils
protègent et il est évident que ce n'est
pas parce que je suis vacciné je ne peux
lever toutes les mesures de prévention
de distanciation social effet marièrent
de geste l'arrière pour me protéger moi
et pour protéger toutes les personnes
aujourd'hui porter le masque garder la
distance respecter les personnes de ce
que je rentre dans un endroit où je me
balade dans la rue en portant le masque
celle-ci de respect c'est un signe
d'engagement un signe d'amour pour les
personnes on sente avec moi et je me
dois de continuer le faire même si c'est
contraignant même si c'est kelly fixé
c'est difficile je peux le comprendre
nous sommes un grand pays et nous sommes
une grande nation chacun d'entre nous
peut être fier d'être ici
ils ne vont continuer à respecter ses
règles pour notre intérêt dont entre
intérêts dont l'intérêt pour leurs
concitoyens
merci beaucoup henrique casalino chef
des urgences à l'hôpital bichat à paris
d'avoir été avec nous